all right
morning ladies and gents good morning
you have some amazing mornings
amazing i'm going to start off with
that's all right and
rattle down and ask you all a question
each then throughout our very big
audience today
and get some questions from these guys
charlie i'm going to start with you and
the physical side of the the comedy in
this film is is uh
is kind of important but you kind of
come off the worst would you agree
uh yeah the worst in the film
no that's what i was going to say i i i
meant
i get the bronzer for the most i do
suffer the most yeah yeah
um and uh i i did physically too yeah i
got a little beat up
but it's an important part of the film
would you agree in terms of that kind of
slapstick element to it
uh yeah yeah i think uh you know um
a little physical humor is is nice every
now and then
it travels well yeah and travels
overseas jason
um which one you you're next
to charlie i'm going down the line so
um cart's this yes guy
yes um are you a yes guy are you a bit
more kind of
i'm not so sure type of guy i i i'm
eventually a yes guy maybe maybe in my
real life i ruminate a little bit more
than i should but i think that's just
the virgo nature
um what's your rising though yeah yeah
uh i don't know usually like uh i don't
know
nine ten o'clock yeah somewhere around
hey it
depends on our body um i don't need to
be here
but yeah i come from the back uh like
improv background and the one of the
the commandments is uh yes and you
support and you add and so yeah i think
kurt
if he's never taken a a class at second
city he should because he's got a real
knack for it
jennifer welcome
jennifer i'd like to ask you please what
did you enjoy
about revisiting this character and
playing
dr julia once again what do you love
about it the most
what enjoy about it uh i have to say
well i just love her in general i think
she's quite
um snazzy uh and i
i loved i loved just putting on her her
wardrobe and i loved
my her wig and the accessories her
accessories
which only one person really was aware
of what my lovely necklace really was
mr jason sedakis gives you a little
insight into um
his personal i love catalogs
i bend the pages you know the corners
yes um with you guys coming back to
revisit these characters
did you did you get to be um have more
control
over things with this film whether that
be script
and casting of you know new characters
and things like that i would say
i'd say input would probably be a better
term
for it um and uh yeah it was very very
generous of the studio and
and sean and john sean anders and john
morris the writers of the film
to uh include us in
including jennifer in in in in our
thoughts for
for what this sequel might look and
sound like
um we're all keenly aware that sequels
are
are difficult to do well um and
we didn't want to be lazy with that we
were all really appreciative that the
first one did well and
i wanted this one to to be at least as
good and
uh and hopefully better okay i'm going
to throw it to our audience now
uh right the front row mama the red
trainer's on
hi good morning i'm a uv from israel and
my question is
hi what is your horrible job that you
had before you start working on
television and
cinema your horrible job get it out of
the way right up front
yeah yeah i was a a telemarketing
in which company what did you do i was
trying to sell timeshares in the poconos
and i say trying yeah i didn't i didn't
actually ever sell one
i was never good at sales either i had a
few jobs like retail like working at
banana republic and
and uh yeah i could never that would
have been fun where you take the little
cardboard thing and you might
fold the t-shirt i don't need it i don't
even need it i can do it again you just
created it
yeah it looks great no it looks great
it was the selling it was like upselling
oh yeah trying to improve my upt's units
per
transaction i just couldn't do it with
this charm in that face
that's very sweet of you wait are you
being sarcastic no i'm being 100
people i just i didn't give up i would
just laugh my way and just be like you
are so cute that [ __ ]
shirt i'm going to take that little i
wish you would have come through banana
republic
thank you that's it
jason charlie do you want to answer that
oh i cleaned people's toilets
i knew that so that's why yeah i did i
did yeah if you went to the gym
and you defecated and you did not flush
uh that was my problem oh man so you
just flushed toilets
i just flushed toilets a mop from a
distance
bateman no i never did flesh toilets in
prison no um i um
i i started acting when i was very very
young so i never had to work for a real
boss
uh but uh worse jobs would um maybe uh
teen wolf two would be right
up there not true that's not true
in retrospect was fun
okay next question uh lady there in the
stripy top can we go
pass the microphone along there please
hi um i'm victoria from film 360
magazine
jason from horrible bosses hey how you
doing you guys okay
um i just wanted to say that um a lot of
you guys have worked together before in
previous films so does that make it more
comfortable on set and is it fun to
reunite
absolutely 100 percent yes we actually
only really
we but it is a luxury actually to to
a b be friends with these people and and
love and adore them on a personal level
and then to be able to
have worked together separately
together and together together um
it's it's it's kind of a dream job it
would be terrible if we didn't like each
other you know because i mean
you're doing the the fact that you're
doing comedy
you need to have like a nice free fun
set like there's like there's a good
vibe in here so like the press
conference is fun you're like
if we hated each other you'd feel it and
it would just be like
you've seen it i'm sure you probably
have better stories about it than we do
yeah i was i was looking forward to
doing this yeah you know there's nothing
that's part of
one of the things that the three of us
talked about we got on the phone
together when they first said you know
do you want to do a sequel
the three of us called each other we
talked about junketing and we talked
about traveling and and
be like this right here we this is part
of the fun for us so
um yeah it's uh it's really rare when
you find people that
you like this much and then you get to
do two movies
it's it's great jason called it uh movie
camp it is it's like moving
yeah on the plane here i was on the
plane and we we saw
a benedict [ __ ] uh yeah and we all
descended upon him and and i think he
signed up for the third
yeah horrible boss is three he's the
other the new boss
that's announced i'm announcing that
here yeah there you go someone should
let him know
you'll let him know
i had a phone call with christopher yeah
but i don't talk about horrible jobs
about horrible bosses
and he said the special in this business
you cannot
avoid to have horrible bosses sometimes
do we'll have some experiences
maybe without uh saying the name of
someone
could you tell us a little bit about
that like a director or a producer or a
studio head something like that
yeah no name for example
all of the above names
yeah yeah that's it that's all you can
really say without naming names
you've limited the answer to one word
let's talk about crystal volts instead
it's a good idea let's talk about
crystal volts instead who does the best
impression of him
i've heard you all do a mean
sudeikis has got the corner on no i'm
pregnant charlie i i
charlie just tickles me to no end giving
you limbering up
the jaw goes up like this when it tucks
you know like the chin is always up i do
not
it's good that's all right that's all i
have
this is really terrible he's not here to
defend he can't defend him you should
hear his charlie day impression that's
that's too easy what's that
no [ __ ] oh back to your question yeah
yeah they didn't say yes but you said
not to name names
that's awesome there's a journalist that
really
really gets uh you know wants his point
wants his
answer and just you know we'll stop
something dead in its tracks to double
back on it
it's been years since i've had to go
through that um
but yeah no i've had some pretty yeah
you have producers people that that
don't believe in
uh the movie-making experience to be
collaborative and
push their own agenda and their own uh
shitty sense of humor
on you and and you know what do you do
either
yeah or or don't come prepared and don't
do their homework when
there's that version on the directing
side on the directing side when you know
your
your actors have done their part and
then when the the other side is not
prepared and you're just kind of winging
it for them and
no fun unless it's a documentary yeah
yeah exactly
okay gentlemen in the front row there
get a question please
uh question for jennifer just down here
um there's an illuminating scene in the
credits
uh where you say i can't deliver that
line
yeah and i just wondered what was it
well you don't deliver it so no i don't
i don't i actually can't remember what
the line was but i have been reminded by
somebody where that had to do with gravy
um and an undercarriage well i wonder
what the last right
i don't know what that means yeah and i
guess when ooh
yeah it's a holiday meal yeah
it's not i don't i think gravy's funny
and
sexual no that's why it's not in the
movie yeah we got rid of it
didn't test well but i wondered what
line you had actually delivered that
made you squirm the most and whether
this is a sign that um this character is
as far away from
the real you as as you've ever got
well in language yes i would say i mean
you know
suck it like a bomb bomb what is it
suck it like a bomb pop down to the blue
is not something that normally comes
sort of tripping off of my tongue
that should be a nicki minaj song
these little girls will be dancing to it
like you know it's like in the car
daddy put on suck it like a bomb
and then parentheses down to the blue
okay gentlemen a bit further along in
the front row if we can get the mic
that's going to happen and you should
get something on that you're going to be
in the video game
they're going to loop your voice right
there
sorry uh putting aside the cinematic you
know opus that was teen wolf two for
most of you this is yeah that's the
first sequel
i'm trying if you could talk about the
sort of hesitations that would come with
approaching a comedy sequel
well just that they're usually bad um
and and most of it is is sort of a false
negative i think
because you know you're not surprised
with this with the second one and and so
you kind of you take it as as bad
because it seems kind of stale
by definition so we knew that we weren't
going to get any points for
you know talking fast and over one
another and acting stupid like we did in
the first one we're
going to deliver that but that wasn't
going to be enough so we tried to
find some complexities in the plot and
and give it a little bit more of a
visual style and
and um you know grab another oscar
winner
you know a lady there and then too long
after that
thanks um jennifer we seem to be in the
midst of another wave of feminism at the
moment and as a woman
are we in another wave of it another
wave
get your trunks on why
anyone got any wings as a woman who's
spoken out about feminist issues and a
woman working in an industry that's been
criticized as being sexist
i wondered what changes you've seen both
positive
and negative for women in your career
well i think one positive is that there
have been many
many more movies with female leads and
and on some sorry and ensembles and
and those movies are doing really well
so i think that's
fantastic i think um
for me personally i i loved that dr
julia was sort of
taking the role of what would normally
be a male
character in in a film you mean a
dentist oh
yeah yeah you don't see a lot of female
dentists
i guess you don't yeah but i think it's
i think it's i think it's good but it is
there still is
sexism it just sort of exists double
standards all that stuff
lady you're in the front room and then
we'll come over the other side and say
hi my name is celia i come from spain
um i would like to put her the other way
what kind of
poses are you in your real life um
jennifer i have to tell you that i
adored you
i am a big fan of you i seen all your
movies i think that you are
great um actress no just in the comedy
i see the drama you are fantastic thank
you
oh i love you too we should meet after
that can we get out of here
i feel like we need to be left alone
yeah yeah
box of tissues please on this side yes
very good question for you as well
how difficult is to to be in the role of
women which is completely obsessed with
sex
how is it to be in at mike the mean the
the woman who
is obsessed with sex i think it's
hysterical
and i find it quite amusing because i
don't think to her
she's it's there's anything wrong or or
deviant about
herself i think she actually is
described describes sex and
approaches sex as as though a chef
approaches a wonderful meal
to be made or or you know i think it's
kind of just
a very common place for her and it's
sort of it's like a sport
i think it's fantastic and the other
question was was what kind of bosses are
you all
great really yeah
fair fair there we go uh we got jim in
the second roll there please
get a microphone too if we do the one
closest with the
mustache mr moustache mrs movember you
go first and then the one of these polar
mustaches
thank you very much for my question oh
it's just dirt uh
christopher sports how you fabulous
moustache in the movie
uh apart from charlie obviously you got
the full bid were
you tempted to grow uh moustaches
yourselves
uh jenny can answer that question as
well i missed this entire question i
just heard a mustache and then i just
noticed charlie
the question was were you tempted to
grow a mustache was i yeah i already
have just like kristoff's in the in the
movie
no i've worn a mustache at times in my
life
um our first movie together i had one
you did
our first movie together you had a
mustache they're very very healthy
did you shoot those at the same time
yeah same mustache too same mustache
we started the movie how about that yeah
six degrees of my mustache and gentlemen
at the end please in the blue shirt
hi i'm jan from belgium question for
jennifer
um did you feel men reacted uh
differently towards you when you were
wearing this
dark brown wig
with these guys no or other men
in general men in general uh well no on
set
there was i think that it kind of got
old after the first day
it was pretty pretty and then you washed
it then i washed it and then
yeah there was it was no no
everyone knew it was a character but i
don't think anyone really i think people
watching it
felt differently about just seeing that
that visual was was just fun for people
but we didn't i didn't get treated any
different
i still like yeah gentlemen in front if
you can pass my tim and then we'll come
over to you guys in a second
hi again hello my question is what is
your personal dream
something that you want to achieve in
your private life in a professional
dream
by the way my private dream is to have a
selfie with jennifer
oh yeah that's a private dream yeah yeah
maybe you can help me later i think
dreams can come true
let's see oh they keep starting tonight
my dreams remain dreams
so what is your profession a
professional dream and your personal
dream and
myself later yeah i'm gonna take world
peace and uh throw it to you for
personal and professional
oh wow in a second that i think that's a
great dream don't we all have that dream
i think that's the universal dream you
all have
okay we're gonna go over here to the uh
the checked shirt please
hi there um there's quite a few american
comedies that deal with
the recession kind of economic issues
and
such as uh the other guys does and also
horrible bosses and horrible horses too
like they seem to bother just to name
three yeah yeah
he's checking just checking um was that
something that
made you interested in taking these two
films because
there seems to be that sort of kind of
depth to it and something that they both
are informed by
it helps if you know if there's
something truthful
to build the comedy on top of so i think
uh
certainly that was there in the first
movie and in the second movie
when we were asked for our input we
wanted to find something that
the audience can kind of hang their hat
on and say all right i can relate
a little bit to that struggle and then
we can go and uh you know pretend to
jerk each other off or whatever it is
we're doing the movie but um
you know it it helps that there's
something spoilers
something for the audience relate to i
think we're not exactly teaching lessons
but i think it's good that it's there
yeah there's no preaching it's merely
just a reflection of of things that are
you know unless you're looking to learn
how to jerk a guy off yeah
then we got you and then yeah watch the
first scene and then you can split and
then you can leave
uh but yeah it's it's nothing that that
we're trying to convince anybody of or
it's just merely a reflection of of of
what's going on in the world and you
know big conversation
out there especially in the states is
the 99 versus the one percent it's been
going on since
you know for years but even more so
since the 20th election
since when since david and goliath yeah
that's right that's true yeah and so
we're just you know trying to
throw some throw some rocks at that big
summer [ __ ]
read your bible again we'll sweeten it
afterwards
in fact or i can improve the jokes
there's there's
that's halfway how about that yes my dad
back here in the
time um the way the film is does leave a
door open
for a horrible bosses three you just
suggested that
is it a possibility and would you all
welcome the chance to come back to it
well people have to buy tickets for this
one first it pays for it
yeah so um you know it was it was a
great phone call to get
uh after the first one um but again
it came on the heels of uh a nice warm
reception from the public so uh
hopefully people are
equally kind to this one would any of
you look direct in the next one
i think about it about directly direct
in the next one
i would love fantastic director any of
these people would do a great job at it
it's taste execution after all
gentlemen at the end of this side during
the credits
the some of the lines were so hilarious
you were corpsing over them
but i just wondered uh during the actual
shooting
there's nothing more serious sometimes
than comedy how
difficult did you find it actually to
make scenes as funny as those with the
various
characters after all talking one pulling
another cetera because you could see all
the laughter at the end but
was it actually quite a tough shoot it's
um well you know you hear any joke
enough times you're not going to laugh
at it anymore so you know you're not
seeing take one uh
take one two and three we're we're
useless because there's a lot of
laughing but um
we usually show you take seven or
something like that where we're all
bored of it and uh can't stand the sound
of each other's voice anymore
um or you just pinch your inner thigh
you know that'll get the smile off your
face
yeah things that make us break more
often are are like the setups you know
or or
when we are um you know tiny little
inside jokes that occur with the crew
uh less less less so the punch lines
because we've we've been involved from
pre-production we
you know we've read the script for the
most part and uh
and then yeah you're just executing the
jokes but it's it's the joy of getting
to do that for a living when you're when
you're caught in that moment you can't
help but
but laugh yeah what was really getting
me was this one sequence where we're uh
describing uh the plot for the
kidnapping and we have to
be fairly serious and we haven't been
serious for like a month at that point
and uh and these two would not let me
say a serious line without
really really making me not believe in
myself
i couldn't get through it then i could i
you know i couldn't take myself
seriously either
we're all trying to be badasses we were
trying to do our best chris mine
and we just yeah and then we went to
lunch and i asked the director if i
could secretly come back and do it with
them not there and then that's the only
way i got through it
did you do it like that yeah i did
that's hilarious
yeah because i didn't want you there
what about the scenes with them with
them mr spacey because
i mean this kind of whole look you said
last night jason that was kind of his
his idea that this diamond he starred
and and stuff and
i mean how did you manage to get through
those particular scenes
that was actually a tough one for me
because they they were having to
uh the in the scene they were trying to
see what he was saying just by reading
his lips and so every single take they
would make up different things they
never told me what it was
um it really kept really difficult an
amazing straight face
that's very very tight honestly that was
if you could hear the horrible thoughts
in my head
to keep a smile off my face you'd be
disgusted
okay question from the lady in the
middle there
hi guys um you already said like e3 you
guys look forward to doing the press
tours and things like that
jen how do you find it being kind of the
only lady like you
see yourself as one of the lads does it
get quite laddy and well i'm
sadly left out of their this is the most
fun i'm having because i get to be with
the guys they're
they have each other and i i'm sort of
left on my own
in in the room but i mean i get more
one-on-one time with everyone so i guess
that's you nice folks let her finish
but i do i mean i these are fun
especially
when you love the movie so much and you
love the the cast that you get to
play with and hang out with and fly with
and we we just have
a great time i don't feel like one of
the lads though i do feel like
i still feel like a lady nice question
uh gentlemen down the front here
mike turn please
see some hands as well if you've got
more questions just wondering uh how
many of you actually took one of the
shower buddy props
home with you and also what were the
aborted sort of attempts
before they settled on the shower buddy
shower buddy was the first one
believe it or not that it became a red
herring so we
ran up the flagpole a few ideas and even
tried to make the shower buddy more
elaborate um
uh in regards to what about it was
something that someone would want to buy
like uh you know there's a function that
switched the valve from
shampoo to conditioner and maybe nasa
would be involved with that you know
just making it more
would pop out at one point what was that
a loofah yeah yeah there are all these
different ideas
uh but uh but no surprisingly we did not
we did not we couldn't top it
yeah we couldn't top it and just
wonderfully dumb enough but made enough
sense that
it was believable and then it
accidentally looked like the starship
enterprise yeah i don't know if you
noticed that that was an accident
yeah is it one of you guys doing the
shower body pose on the uh on the box
no they didn't want our bodies on that
yeah or our faces or anything
yeah no interest we're gonna go right to
the back to the gentleman with the
camera
oh no we're not we're gonna go with that
man first okay you go first and then
we'll go straight to the back of the man
can't ask questions
go on yeah you go with your you've got
the microphone go for it
yeah the yellow microphone go for it go
speak now go
go he has the flu we met him earlier
nope still you oh yeah still you you can
do it
sound it out sound it out cool yeah i
would like to ask
all of you no not you
i'm kidding okay i would like to ask all
of you
if you used even once your authority in
a very very bad way
and because almost all of you in the
movie have some weird and bizarre
nicknames
if you do have a nickname in your
ordinary life and you would like to
share it with all of us
excuse me gentlemen master bateman's
always been a good one for me master
bateman
been tough you've never elected to be
called that though no no no no
no well you can't pick your own nickname
can you
i mean no i mean we try in the movie you
know but uh
right yeah well we're idiots yeah those
are code names code names are different
than nicknames that's true
you can elect your own code name i don't
have a nickname yeah do i
no jen jen that's like a
shortening of my name yeah although in
high school i was
well there was a lot of jen jennifer's
in my cl
in my grade so we all had different so
i was jenna bean oh and then i was jojen
it's not so bad no it's just not
impressive what does the b stand for
huh what are the b stand you say gen b
jenna bean or jenna b
oh gosh what'd the joe stand for yeah my
middle name is joanna
got it there it is so you got a dyslexic
class jojen
charlie i i i go by my my nickname my
name is
charles but uh i i never only my my my
mother calls me that and uh
and i never felt comfortable with it so
i everyone else in the neighborhood
called me charlie and i just preferred
it
jason tell them that's not a nickname oh
yeah that's not nice
it's an abbreviation come on man uh suds
um jeff and joe wilcox who lived next
door to me called me suds at a very
young age and then
throughout my life people have uh have
done that
uh yeah so it's been i have your suds in
my phone
do you yeah nice see probably because i
wasn't confident enough to spell your
name
oh it's a mess who knows how to spell
this damn thing god for auto correct
last question the man with the camera at
the back of the room
how do you turn this camera on
guys first of all thank you so much for
being with us today i think we've
enjoyed it as much as you have
my question is to jennifer um jen
obviously this is one of the first times
you've had a chance to revisit a
character and it's obviously been
a wonderful comedic reunion with the
boys but i think the one comedic reunion
we're all very curious
about is friends and whether or not that
would ever be something that you'd be
interested in
are you gonna do a friend's two
you get to be chandler and jason
you get to be joey oh that means you'd
be ross
hey
i've never seen the show what are you
referring to and there's coot there's
kudrow down at the end yeah there you go
yes i don't know i don't think so
honestly i think we should wait
until we're really old and then maybe
reunite
senior friends yeah golden friends
golden friends
that could have a completely different
that's right that's right
they pee on each other
charlie we got it i just wanted to spell
it out i think we should end this
now and thank you so much for being a
great audience and great question
thank you thank you you're amazing
amazing actors
to charlie jason jennifer and jason